okay well I suppose I should make a sort  of introduction of mine myself I was  born a few months after the atom bomb  was dropped on Hiroshima as born in  November of 46 I'm gonna double scorpion  award and born in western Colorado and  lived there till I was 16 came to  California  finished high school here went to Cal  was around Berkeley for eight or nine  years when I wasn't in Asia and I was in  Asia locked first in the Seychelles  where I tried to emigrate emigrate then  in India mostly smuggling hash and  buying art and then when that became  untenable I went to Indonesia and  collected butterflies for Singapore  Chinese for a while and then taught  English in Japan  and then went to the Amazon in 71 and  that trip to the Amazon is the subject  of a book I wrote called  to true hallucinations